Okay, so that's going to be it for this Unreal Engine training session.
We did an introduction to Lighting for architecture, engineering, and construction industries.
The topics we covered were Lighting terminology and types.
We had a common language for stuff like Direct Lighting and Indirect Lighting, and the types
of lights that we actually use.
We took a look at how to control exposure and the tools that we have available to that.
We looked at Lumen as the default rendering engine in UE5.
And then we went ahead and set up some Lighting scenarios for natural exterior lighting.
We took a look at reflections and how to optimize them, as well as some setups for interior
lighting inside of the Unreal Engine.
I hope you had fun, and I'll see you in the next training session.